[ Indistinct conversations ]
-We've been here for like
seven hours already.
-I've been here for five hours.
-Who among us knows
the purpose of this meeting?
-Well, the host did not say,
Lord Black Thought.
-And, alas, my little birds
have told me nothing.
But, regrettably,
one of my little birds
decided to drop a deuce
upon my tunic.
♪♪♪♪
-You may be seated.
I have summoned this meeting of
the regular-sized council
to answer one question
and one question only.
-Laurel, My Lord.
An answer to your question.
I once thought it to be yanny,
but in point of fact,
the voice does say "Laurel."
-I seek the answer to one
question and one question only.
How long must we [bleep]
wait for "Game of Thrones"?!
-The TV show, My Lord?
-"Game of Thrones" is no mere
TV show, Lord Black Thought.
It's a way of life.
A hallowed epic cruelly
torn from our bosoms
by a production hiatus
most vile.
Winter has come and gone.
And then winter
has come and gone again.
And now 'tis spring,
and one thing is clear.
Shorts weather is coming.
So, I shall ask one more time.
When will
"Game of Thrones" return?
-I've had the same question,
My Lord.
For two years, I've had nothing
to watch, nothing to binge,
nothing to amuse me
but the memory of my balls.
-I got a question for you.
Why am I paying more for
HBO still? Why?
-The wait, indeed,
has been long.
I myself have been forced
to watch...broadcast.
-And does anyone like
"Young Sheldon?"
Does anyone like it?
Like, genuinely like it,
for real?
-Is there no one
who can answer my question?
-Might I suggest, My Lord,
perhaps we do not want
"Game of Thrones" to return.
-What?
[ Laughs ]
-Not want it to return?
-Yes.
-What is this blasphemy?
-Oh, he is cray, My Lord.
The man is cray-cray.
-Shame!
-No! My Lord, it is simply that
if the show does not return,
then it cannot come to an end.
-He's got a good point.
That's actually a pretty good
point right there.
-It is true, My Lord.
The show cannot end
if it does not return.
It would remain forever in
the realm of what still may be.
-Lord Higbones, all great shows
must come to an end.
A great show does not overstay
it's welcome.
"Game of Thrones" must end,
but in order for it to end,
it must [bleep] begin.
When will it --
-Silence!
Patience, My Lord.
Your temper will not hasten
the end you seek.
The premiere is coming.
But until then,
we mustn't lose our heads.
Do you get it?
-No.
-"Mustn't lose our heads."
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
You get it?
"We mustn't lose our heads."
[ Laughs ]
It's good, isn't it, that?
Funny.
-I don't -- I don't get it.
-No matter, Higbones.
We are no closer to the answer.
When will "Game of Thrones" --
-April 14th.
-What's that you say, good man?
-The final season premieres
April 14th.
But have no fear.
After the show ends,
there will still be books.
-Mysterious stranger, how do we
know that you speak the truth?
-Trust me. I know a guy.
-The premiere is coming.